does anyone work here anyone apparently
not but that will stop us from dropping
off a few of these complaints we know
technology has a lot of annoyances we
hear about them from you every week and
we have some too so this week we're
taking three minutes to make our biggest
concerns heard the first one goes out to
Apple iOS updates are great until they
slow down your old iPhone or iPad to the
point that you can't even use it anymore
Apple of course wants to keep the ball
moving forward with technology but it
also happens to be one of their best
ways to get us to buy new stuff what
they should do is provide security
updates for old operating systems and
provide compatibility for old apps
Android users have a totally opposite
problem some of us never get the updates
Google promises us right now only 3.3
percent of Android devices run Android
5.0 lollipop the version released five
months ago and even when some phones do
get that version it will likely be
tarnished by the phone makers own tweaks
Samsung HTC and others need to follow a
company like Motorola which releases
software updates faster because it
doesn't add too much to the operating
system itself gadgets have gotten
incredibly thin but do we really need to
slice cheese with our phones the problem
is that the thinner they get the worse
our batteries seem to become a few
months into using this iPhone 6 I
already have to carry around a battery
backup phone makers listen up we would
gladly accept another few millimeters
maybe even a centimeter if it meant that
our batteries would last longer enough
about phones it's 2015 why is it so hard
to print something first there's the
problem of wireless printing sometimes
it works sometimes I'm not sure where
it's printing out ink cartridges are
still at least thirty dollars a pop
unless you buy those off-brand ones and
then after a year or two they always
break down but there is no paper jam I
don't know how it should happen I just
know that some company needs to make
living with a printer a whole lot easier
passwords may be the biggest bane of our
digital era they're hard to remember and
there
even that safe password managers can
help but they feel like a stopgap with
fingerprint sensors and cameras that can
ID our irises why are we still punching
strings of letters and numbers we can't
remember into laptops our computers
should be smart enough to know who we
are by now this is my 15 page Verizon
bill from last month
what's a gross receipts err charge our
monthly cable and cellular bills whether
we get them digitally or via regular
mail seem to be purposely confusing I'm
never quite sure where my money is going
and why this fine print is needed what
they need to do is streamline this
without using it as an excuse to
conveniently hide things
props to AT&T for the video explainers
but you know there's a problem when we
need videos to explain these bills
listen technologies are work in progress
but sometimes these companies make
decisions that don't put our best
interest at heart you know what happens
when you complain enough it gets
annoying and people start listening we
want to hear your complaints to email us
at personal tech at wcco.com and tweet
us too